bucha hace un año cuerpos yacen en las
calles hombres y mujeres dejados al aire
libre junto a sus bicicletas sus carros
y sus casas estas fueron las escenas que
siguieron luego de que las fuerzas
ucranianas retomaron el control de la
ciudad a inicios de abril estos vídeos
de seguridad parecen mostrar a personas
siendo conducidas bajo amenaza por la
caída blusca después de La retirada rusa
las fuerzas ucranianas encontraron los
cuerpos de 20 civiles algunos con las
manos atadas a la espalda
hoy los residentes de la ahora infame
calle están tratando de superar el
pasado pero los recuerdos aún están
frescos en la mente incluso para los más
jóvenes
no teníamos teléfonos ni electricidad
nos sentamos en nuestros pops dormimos
sobre ellos y cuando volvimos a salir
había sangre por todas partes
el rastro de los daños dejado por la
invasión va más allá de los autos y
casas destruidas
duermo y no estoy segura de cómo voy a
huir tengo esta mochila lista en todo
momento
un año después bucha ha entrado en una
nueva fase una de reconstrucción con la
esperanza de que esto ayude a cerrar un
capítulo doloroso
hay un deseo de liberarnos de cualquier
cosa que pueda recordarnos que los rusos
estuvieron aquí
este deseo está en el corazón el alma y
la mente de cada habitante
en julio pasado la organización para la
seguridad y la cooperación en Europa
concluyó que los asesinatos cometidos
por las fuerzas rusas equivalían a
crímenes de guerra